151 hours that's how long remains until
the Iowa caucuses six days from right
now you should be arriving at your
caucus place don't be late okay the
future and destiny of America could very
well be decided Monday night in Iowa
you're going to be the first state in
the country that Americans are going to
hear from and it's either Donald Trump
or its Ted Cruz so I don't believe Iowa
can be one from Manhattan TV studio or
DC several of things that we considered
going to with Trump they were always big
events they were never in the in the
small coffee shops whereas Cruz is
probably more grassroots than what
Donald Trump is awesome I told him who
we'd be praying for him and told him
there will be caucusing for him on
Monday night this is our first time to
really be involved in the caucus I will
be here until all of you are gone in
essence i will stay here as long as it
takes to shake every hand take every
picture kiss every baby sign every book
there are a lot of undecided voters in
Iowa and we're gonna get Marco around
the state a lot this weekend and I think
as they hear his message they're gonna
come our way and so we feel really good
about where we're at now how will you be
caucusing for senator Rubio on Monday
I'm prepared to support Marco Rubio I
think I committed to review tonight it
was tonight for me I just like what he
has to say the aligns with my beliefs
we're continuing
our bus tour across the state of Iowa
the Iowa caucuses are 147 hours commit
today to come out next monday and caucus
forth I thought it was pretty humbling
for Ted Cruz to walk in this old church
in small-town Bloomfield Iowa come in
here dress down like we were and kind of
you know just kick it with us for about
20 mess monday I plan to go out to the
caucus and support Ted Cruz she was kind
of on the fence coming in here today
I've been a huge ben Carson lover and
I've kind of I've kind of been in favor
of Marco Rubio and so this that kind of
sealed the deal for me we've got now
over twelve thousand volunteers here in
the state we're making over 20 pounds of
phone calls a day our volunteers
reaching out to voters I think that
you're gonna see a kind of a get out to
go that vote effort on the part of the
Cruz campaign that we've not seen on the
part of Republicans maybe ever even if
its cold even if it's snowing we've got
to get out hopefully by the end of this
event we have earned your support and if
we have please fill out one of these
commit to caucus cards these are
commitment cards so we sign that with a
community supporting marker with the
caucuses we've been working very hard
for the last nine months it's a huge
effort I mean we make tens of thousands
of phone calls and so it takes a lot of
volunteers but over the last especially
over the last two or three months as
people decide that they want to support
Marco those numbers have ramped up a lot
I ask you to please sign up so we can
stay in touch with you we're not going
to bombard you with email what we are
going to bombard you with emails for
like five more days all you're
committing to is you'll show up next
Monday night seven o'clock you'll sit
through about an hour meeting go right
down Marco Rubio on that piece of paper
and you can leave that's all we're
asking someone my age I have three kids
I have to find a babysitter so I can go
to the meeting for two hours and so it
might cost me forty to fifty dollars
just to go caucus so convincing people
how important it is and getting them out
to caucus is always a challenge I think
time is always an issue
we'll make time because it's important
you know it takes some commitment and
the willingness to be able to speak but
it doesn't seem like a difficult thing
or something that's want to take you
know tons of time this is the time for
the men and women of Iowa ask you number
one to join us in number two to bring
others if every one of you gets nine
other people to show up in caucus you
will have voted ten times that is how we
win pray about 10 times I think that's a
tremendous idea we will be taking some
people with us to caucus I think they'll
be really tough to rag them with you and
say hey you're gonna go with me and
we're gonna vote for the same guy I'm
not sure that's realistic commit today
to come out next monday night and caucus
for a stand up and speak for us be with
us when you go caucus next Monday night
we must choose a nominee for this party
that wins and I will win god bless the
great state of our thank you thank you
very much thank you thank you very much